There's granola. It's pretty good.
What's up, guys?
I'm gone.
workshop set up. So, um
>> [clears throat]
>> there's some people who kind of have
like never installed Open Claw, and I
want to kind of get them set up. And
then the other people like
want to try an experimental thing, which
I haven't even fully gotten working, but
I think for more advanced people that'll
be cool um to get like a sort of staging
environment and run two Open Claws. So,
I think if I'm not, you know, too busy
helping new people set up, then I'll try
to help people like finish debugging the
last part, or maybe someone else will
get it.
And then I think uh 10 minutes Q&A, 10
minutes some more advanced topics,
and then just more Q&A.
And uh probably after every 5 minutes or
so, we can do a bit of a few minutes of
discussion.
So, I'll just set some timers to make
sure I don't go off track.
All right.
Let me start.
All right. Can everyone see this
presentation?
>> Yes.
>> All right, cool.
Yep.
So,
this kind of describes like my setup. Um
I'll just keep it really high level for
this part where
when everything works, you know, maybe
like 70% of the time, you describe your
task.
And then what's nice is OpenClaw will
have like context and memory about what
you're talking about.
So, for example, like let's say I'm
like, all right, fix this thing.
It's a very brief Slack message, but
OpenClaw can remember like what I've
asked it to do before.
So, for example, I'm working on this
thing I'm calling a skeptic agent, and
it's a custom code review thing.
But if I'm like, all right, fix the
skeptic agent or whatever, right? It
kind of knows what that is, which is
nice.
You have to re-explain a lot.
Um I use multiple agents with work
trees. That's very key for
parallelization.
Uh CI code
integration.
But you can kind of see you can talk to
it and be pretty brief, and then
you know, usually get reasonable
outcomes, but sometimes you'll have to
debug it.
So, then it's like, all right, there's
some timeout thing. I'm like, give it a
longer timeout, right?
And then I asked it here like like uh
you know, what are the priorities in
what we're working on.
And then I'm reading it here.
And And I might have just said like
All right.
I just make code for it, right?
So another interesting thing about this
is you can kind of see from like um
>> [clears throat]
>> the types of responses I give, they're
not that like um
special. As in I I actually think an
agent could replace me.
So that's kind of what I'm working on
right now to like
get things even more autonomous.
You know, and you'll see this with LLMs
like you're working with them and
they'll be like
hey, I've got this thing ready and I'm
like okay, well run the test, right?
All right. So
I'll show the next slide now.
Oops.
Okay.
We're going to some concepts right now
like what is open claw? So
I think what's cool about open claw is
it's not just about a particular repo or
the code, but more of the concept. So
you know, I've got this cool super
diagram, but
first concept is frictionless
communication.
So I know we have other things like
cloud co-work or whatever, but I think
they still have a similar concept where
it's like
can you like easily talk to your AI
versus like you've got a um remote
desktop into your computer or you have
to go sit down. So that kind of enables
certain really higher level of velocity.
Um then I think the central axis is very
important. So
you know, there there's a spectrum like
I kind of
go like a little more cowboy and I give
it access.
Open claw has these agent orchestrator
managers that manage your workers for
you.
Uh or sometimes when I want more
personal control, I use tmux terminals.
So tmux is like a terminal program, but
it's pretty good for parallelization and
um AI development.
Then I use the open source framework
that I forked Asian orchestrator to do
the workers.
And then once it gets to here, this part
is like not really controlled by me as
much anymore. Um, so
I'm calling them managed agents, but
basically like
you have a worker that runs Claude code
and Claude code itself can run agents,
and those can have sub agents.
So once you get to this Claude code
part, right? This part is not exactly my
stack, just stuff I use, but this part
of the stack I'm changing a lot more.
Um, I'll I'll pause here to see if
anyone has any questions or thoughts.
>> Um, can you hear me? I So I have a
question. So
>> Go ahead.
>> The the real question is, you know, why
why use open Claude versus
directly use Claude?
>> So yeah, that's that's definitely a good
question. Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> the reason I use open Claude as
specialization.
So when open Claude makes a decision, I
want that context to be more about
like the spec or the goals or like the
history of what I want in the task
rather than the code.
And you can just imagine this, right? As
soon as you open up Claude, it reads
Claude MDs, it reads skills, it reads um
MCPs.
A lot of those things are sort of
independent of like the actual task.
It's more about how to do the task. Um,
so imagine like 25% of your context
already taken up by implementation.
Versus like when you think about open
Claude, you're like, okay,
I want to think about
exactly what I want to do and how it
relates to all the other slacks Jeff has
sent me in the last 2 weeks and put it
all together and give me like a
reasonable spec.
Does every single thing a player does,
but it does it without a browser, right?
So
you could use MCP, which usually is JSON
or whatever, or HTTP. Doesn't really
matter, actually.
And then the final thing is the browser
test. So, some things like are visual. I
mean, maybe you could even have CSS
tests or JS tests, right? And that kind
of goes here. But then the final thing
is visual.
So, I would recommend you like try um
similar approaches to this and be like,
okay, like which problems truly needed
that human or not. Um and I think what's
kind of cool is like
every quarter, or you maybe even every
month, like it improves.
So, before like I had to really manually
test a lot because like
you know, this worked fine, right? But
these things didn't work that well with
agents like last year, but like a year
ago, even 6 months ago.
But now like um agents are pretty good
at like nailing down a lot of browser
tests for me. Whereas like when I
started my agent would have a lot of
problems, you know, finding a pop-up and
entering a password. Now, no problem.
Um that was a little long, but does that
kind of address the theme of your
question?
>> Yeah, I think this is good. Good. Thank
you.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Just Just remind me for all these slash
commands, I'll put um links here
instead.
All right, cool. Anyone have any other
questions related to some of that stuff?
All right. If not, I will go here.
All right. So, here's
uh
two websites that I've built.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right. While that loads, I'll show
this one.
So, this is like a AI RPG. Um what's
cool about this is you can
I've got a default campaign, for
example.
Um
Yeah. Pick some options. You've got an
avatar.
And uh what's cool about this is it
builds a custom world for you that
reacts to you. So, you can like kind of
say whatever you want, do whatever you
want. You'll get a story back. Um the
main difference between playing this
versus like um you know, you could just
always go into Gemini chat or or chat
GPT or whatever is that
um I have like a D&D system.
So, if you play your own like games or
novels, like you kind of just win too
much. Versus like with this, you'll
actually do like dice rolls and be like,
you know, did the person actually um
did you actually succeed in your action
or not?
All right. So, while this is going on,
let's also um show this thing.
Yeah, so this is funny.
Um this website is like a multi-AI
analysis website. Um
so what I found was like
whenever I was doing research or or
whatever, I would go to multiple models
and I would be like, what's the answer?
Then I copy and paste them all. I put
them into one model.
Um so, pretty simple concept, but this
does it for you. So,
usually I like these answers better than
like asking one model. And I'm like,
okay, how do I do this work?
So, I can be like, okay, what's the
status?
Um what's the latest PR now?
And um
what I like about this is it has that
sort of vertical tab type of thing. Cuz
when you go horizontal, it's really easy
to lose track of your tabs. Um
but we've got notifications, too. So,
when this thing is finished or this is
finished and I need to look, it'll give
me a notification. And I could just
focus on clearing the notifications.
So, here um
the way I've been using these terminals,
usually it's more like a manager rather
than a coder.
Um and it's kind of interesting, but it
gives you a certain benefit where
if you I feel like the work is not
biased anymore. So, when I when I code
with these directly, um
I usually feel like there's a bias where
it wants to say things are really
working or whatever, right? Versus like
you know,
um,
I'll show this.
>> It's okay.
>> If this had been working on PR 294 by
itself, I think it would have been like
this PR is amazing. Like we got to merge
it, right? But then this one was like
no, like there's another PR that should
supersede it and probably we should just
close this PR, right? So that's kind of
the benefit you get where the manager
has a different context
than the workers.
>> [snorts]
>> Uh, let's see.
>> All right, so this is compacting,
whatever. So it will take some time to
complete. Don't want to wait for it, but
when it completes you see these
notifications and I think my efficiency
has improved a lot with Cmux. Um,
I think is Austin or someone from Cmux
here?
>> Yeah, here. What's up?
>> Cool.
Yeah, so Austin is uh,
one [clears throat] of the guys behind
Cmux.
Um, you know, big fan of it and I'm not
I'm not paid to say this or anything,
but I love Cmux. Been using it a lot.
I don't know, you can spend a minute if
you want to talk about anything cool
about Cmux.
>> Yeah, so yeah, one of the creators of
Cmux. Really happy to have Jeff as one
of our power users. And also like kind
of endorsing it for free.
But yeah, lots of
yeah, lots of things that we're
shipping. We shipped a Clockwork Teams
integration. So if anyone is using
Clockwork Teams and wants to actually
see what the sub agents are doing, we'll
automatically spawn terminals for that.
We also shipped Cmux SSH. So if you do
any SSH work, you can use our native
Cmux SSH to, you know, do your tailscale
and etc.
To other computers. You can even use it
to run your own open claw
in your Mac minis.
But yeah, just one of the creators.
Please feel free to email me if you have
anything that you think is a bug or any
feedback, feature request. Um I'm always
available and yeah, just love seeing
people using C marks and always want to
take as much feedback as I can to like
get them as get them in
>> Okay, so just download that.
>> Yeah.
That's how I have an app too. So the app
might be nice.
>> Yeah. Okay.
And then use that to help me get back in
and set set up.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay, cool. Thanks.
>> All right. Does using the sandbox it
should not. Where would you
Have you had Have you run into any
troubles Aaron about sandbox token
usage?
>> Uh no. I'm just I'm
not technical at all.
I have up and running salt so I'm
>> All right.
>> very newbie questions.
>> No, no, no, no, no no bad questions. All
good. Um yeah.
Uh no, no the sandbox wouldn't do that.
Um I think if if everything's working
well for you, you know, keep using the
sandbox.
For me I just, you know, don't use a
sandbox and so so far nothing bad has
happened. But I think if I had an
external bot then I would use a sandbox
too.
>> changing the model testing a new model
like it'll go down then I have to figure
out how to get it back up again. So I
think I want to set up the sandbox
because
>> Oh, sorry, sorry. Um look at it this
way. There's two kinds of things. Okay.
The sandbox that most people talk about
means like they run it in Docker or they
like have it running in an isolated part
of their system.
But the other one was the one where I
made the staging instructions where I
was like, oh
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So
that could double your token usage if
you send the same work to both of them.
If you have two of them, right? But I
think the way I would use it is not like
that. Like
I think I would do local development and
then I would run integration tests on
the
sandbox or staging one, right? So, I
have two of them. And then once like
everything's good, then I would merge
the code and deploy to the production
one.
Um let's see. So, it wouldn't double
your usage, but it would definitely
increase it. But then the benefit is you
might have some more reliability. So,
yeah. I I made some instructions and I
was kind of in the middle of setting it
up, but then you know, it's like
competing with the other one. So, I got
to debug it.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think you know, it's it's worth
trying out though. So, I had that for
more advanced people to give it a
give it a try.
>> Cool. Thanks. What
>> Or if you're not as advanced, if you
want it, you know, you can try it.
>> Yeah, [laughter] I'm I'm definitely
going to play around. But what a what
model do you use? Like do you have a
something that like a default
orchestrator model and then
>> Yeah, so or
I mostly use Codex 53. Um
I found I found GPT 54 to just use more
tokens. Um
And even 53 like
like I I just get destroyed all the
time, right? So, I might have to adjust.
Um so, basically I use this until like
this is getting low and then I just
switch to MiniMax, which
is not as good, but it kind of gets the
job done.
And then this is more about money than
like preference, but
some some work I can still kind of just
do um here. So, I don't always have to